تشاهدون الان على الشاشه من داخل هذه
الجلسه جلسه الكنيست حيث يعرض من يمين
ميتنياهو حكومته امام اعضاء الكنيسه
للتصويت عليها
[تصفيق]
الحكومه الجديده تنطلق في طريق اليوم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ارجو الالتزام بالهدوء
الحكومه الجديده تنطلق اليوم
في مع سنه
75 لاستقلال اسرائيل
لقد وضعنا السياره اسس الاساسيه لكل
مجالات العمل حاربنا اعدائنا الذين فرضوا
علينا الحرب خير والحرب
في السنوات ال 25 القادمه
[موسيقى]
احناجيه فوقعنا على اربع اتفاقيات سلام
تاريخيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
القادمه التي ستحملنا الى
تحمل اسرائيل الى دوله قدوه
مع اسرائيل
دوله
[موسيقى]
قيامها
المهمه الاولى
سلاح حلو
انه والذي سيهددنا ويهدد العالم كله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
قبل الاعضاء الكنيست من المعارضه وهو شعار
لطيف ضعيف